-Our next guest is
an award-winning author
whose new novel, "Eleutheria,"
is available now.
Please welcome to the show
Allegra Hyde, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
First of all, I want to start
by saying you're also from
New Hampshire, and I'm so happy
to have a Granite Stater here.
-Yeah, it's amazing to meet
another person
outside of the state.
-Yeah. Do you feel like
New Hampshire has,
in any way,
informed your work as a writer?
-Definitely. I mean,
I grew up out in the woods,
where, you know,
bears were roaming around,
getting into our garage.
And so I came in close contact
with nature, grew to respect it,
to fear it, and I think
that informs my writing
in this book.
-So, this book is about
sort of a near future
where climate change
is a little bit worse,
which might be
the case in the near future.
What made you choose that
as a jumping-off point?
-Well, I knew I wanted to write
about climate change
and engage with this issue,
and it felt like the near future
was a way to think ahead,
to kind of see
where we're heading,
but not be so far into
a doomsday scenario,
where we can't really
connect with it emotionally.
And so by having
it in that near future,
I could think through
what's gonna happen
and then, more importantly,
how we might problem-solve
and how we might mobilize to --
-Because there is some --
I think people
sometimes worry
when they hear that a book
is about the
future and climate change,
that there won't be
any optimism in it,
but there is a message
of hope in here.
Is that fair to say?
-Yeah. I think
I wanted to show readers
what it might look like
and what it might take
to come together
to solve this crisis.
It's really a book about
activism, ultimately.
I'm of the belief that
we do have the tools right now
to solve climate change.
It's just a
matter of using them.
-"Eleutheria" refers to a
utopian society in this book.
What is the sort of
history of that name?
Where did you --
How did you land on that?
-So, there is a real island
in the Bahamas called Eleuthera.
I named my island Eleutheria
because I wanted to show how
the world in my book is slightly
exaggerated, slightly distorted,
not quite our world
and because it refers to
the original name
that the island had when some
Puritan settlers
showed up there, wanted to start
a utopian community,
and that's the name
that they used.
It eventually changed slightly.
So it's kind of heralding back
to a group of people
who arrived in this place
with an ideal,
and then things went awry,
as they often do.
-So, as a writer,
have been drawn to writing about
utopian societies and sort of
the idea that they --
the center often doesn't hold.
They fall apart pretty quickly
when people go into them
with utopian expectations,
I guess.
-Yeah, I'm really fascinated by
that conflict between
idealism and practicality.
I also have always been
drawn to utopian communities
because I respect the fact that
these groups of people,
these individuals are willing to
step away from the mainstream
and try something different,
knowing that it probably will
fail, but they're trying.
-You've spent some time
in some of these communities
that maybe informed
your writing.
Was it a hippie commune?
Is that a fair way
to describe it?
-Yeah, I spent time
in a lot of hippie communes
in New Zealand, for instance.
There's more hippie communes
there, per capita,
than anywhere else.
-That makes sense.
That seems like
a place where, like --
I feel like if I landed there,
I'd be like,
"I think I'm gonna be a hippie."
And what about -- Not a current,
not an active sex cult,
but a former sex cult?
What's the distinction there?
-Well, this former sex cult
had rebranded
as a health and wellness center.
-How many people
stayed on after the rebrand?
-There were definitely some
people lingering,
and that made it
a little creepy.
-Yeah. And they kind of
were saying stuff like,
"Used to be a lot
more fun around here."
-Yeah, that's pretty much
what it was.
-"This health-and-wellness
thing's alright,
but it used to be
a real banger around here."
-Yeah.
-Now, you are also a teacher.
You're a college professor
at Oberlin in Ohio,
a creative-writing professor.
-That's right.
-How do you like
dealing with students?
Do you do you enjoy that,
talking to young writers?
-Yeah, it's amazing.
They're so inspiring.
Oberlin students
are really incredible.
So I'm so grateful to
have that job.
-And is it true that
you should be teaching tonight?
-Yeah. You caught me.
I'm not in class.
-Will your students
respect the fact that
you are missing class
to be here?
-I hope so.
-You didn't prepare them for it?
-They -- Some of them know.
-Yeah, I gotcha.
And the rest are gonna hopefully
find out in real time.
-Yeah.
-They're gonna be like,
"She doesn't have COVID."
Hey, I'm glad about that
and I'm glad you're here.
Congratulations on the book.
So lovely talking to you,
Allegra.
-Thank you.
-You guys, that's Allegra Hyde.
"Eleutheria" is available
wherever you buy your books,
but please support local
and independent bookstores.
We'll be right back.